So the first thing we're going
to want to do is download and
run our sample application.
Now, I don't actually know where
the zip file is going to
be, but hopefully by the
time this video gets
posted we'll know.
And so thanks to the magic of
YouTube annotations and post
processing and stuff, I'm
going to put it up on
screen right now.
OK.
So I want to follow that link.
Hopefully there'll be
a zip file there
that you can download.
And by the time you unzip it,
you should get something that
looks a little like this.
It's a basic Xcode project.
Let's open it up and take a look
at what we've got here.
Now, the first thing I'm going
to do before I even run it is
change my bundle identifier from
com.example to, well, in
my case com.google.
You should change this to
something that's more
appropriate for your company.
I do find that if you change
the bundle identifier after
you've already run it once, you
end up with two copies of
the game on the simulator and
sometimes it gets confused.
So I like to change it first
before I even run it.
Once that's done, we can run
it and check out our game.
And we are presented with a
fantastic main menu where I
get to pick from an easy,
medium, and hard difficulty
level for the Guess
My Number game.
I'm going to pick an easy game
here and I get to guess a
number between 1 and 100.
So I'm going to start
by guessing 50.
And it's higher than 50.
You'll notice that as it tells
me the value is higher or
lower than what I guessed, the
min and max values here, they
tell me what the minimum and
maximum possible values could
be for our mystery number.
So let's see, I'll guess 85.
It's higher than 85.
How about 92?
Higher than 92.
Wow.
OK.
All right, 95.
Got it in five guesses.
And no it's asking me if
I want to play again.
And I don't think I will,
because that wasn't really all
that much fun.
So we're going to stop this.
And let's get a quick overview
of this application.
I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on this, partly
because it's pretty basic, but
also because there's a very
good chance you are a
better Objective-C
programmer than I am.
So if you find that you're doing
something different than
the way I'm doing it, don't
assume that my way is
necessarily more proper
or more correct
than what you're doing.
There's a very good chance that
you're doing the right
thing and I'm not.
And if so, feel free
to leave some
suggestions in the comments.
I'll read those.
Just don't be a jerk about it.
So first thing we're going to
do, let's take a look at the
app delegate.
What we've got here
is pretty basic.
We're creating an intro view
controller and we're creating
a navigation controller and then
we're simply taking our
intro view controller and making
that the root of our
navigation controller.
We display that on the screen
and we're ready to go.
Let's take a look at our
intro view controller.
We can see here in the nib,
we've got three buttons, easy,
medium, and hard, for
playing on those
different difficulty levels.
If we look at our dot m file,
basically the three buttons
here all call start game with
difficulty with a different
difficulty level.
All start game with difficulty
does is it creates a game view
controller, sets the game
difficulty, and then pushes
that to the top for our
navigation controller.
If you're wondering where these
difficulty levels are
coming from, that's coming from
our Enums.h file, where
we define the difficulty level
as well as a reply Enum that
simply tells the player whether
the guess was too
high, too low, or they got it
just right and they win.
So let's take a look at
our game model next.
In our dot h file, you'll
see we have a number
of properties here.
Game max is the maximum possible
value for any game.
So in a game where I'm guessing
between 1 and 1,000
game max will always be 1,000.
Player min and player max are
the minimum and maximum values
based on the player's
guesses so far.
So you saw when I guessed 50
that it told me it was too low
and that my min and max
where 51 and 100.
That's what player in
and player max are.
Num guesses is the number of
guesses that I've made so far.
Max length is the maximum number
of digits that are
possible in my answer,
and that's based on
the game max value.
And then we have two public
methods, new game with level,
which simply starts a new game
with a particular difficulty
level, and player guessed takes
a guess from the player
and returns one of those reply
Enums that says too high, too
low, or you win.
If we look at the game
model, we can see
most of these methods.
New game with level will define
the game max based on
the difficulty level.
It will generate a secret
number, reset the player min
and player max, reset number of
guesses to 0, and determine
the max length again based
on the number of
digits in game max.
Player guessed increments
the number of guesses.
It will adjust the player min
and player max values as
appropriate depending on what
I've guessed and will return
too high, too low, or
you've won Enum.
So now let's take a look at
the game view controller.
This is probably where most of
the interesting game logic is.
If you look at the nib, we've
got some basic labels, a text
field, a guess button, min and
max labels, a response label,
and a play again button.
If we look at the dot h file,
we really only have one
property here and that's
the game difficulty.
You'll recall that was set by
the intro view controller when
we start a new game.
And finally, in our
dot m file--
let's go to the top here--
we have a number of properties
to represent all of the UI
elements on screen as well as a
game model and a Boolean to
determine whether the game
was over or not.
Start game calls a new game with
level on our game model
and resets a number of
on screen elements.
At that point, it updates the
interface, updates the min/max
labels, and basically just preps
the screen for new game.
Update min/max labels just
updates those labels based on
what we got for the model.
Update interface based on game
over shows or hides various
buttons depending on whether
the game is over or not.
Play again button was pressed,
starts a new game.
Guess button was pressed is
probably where most of the
interesting logic
is in our game.
We take the integer value from
the player's guess and we'll
pass that to our game model
through the public method
player guessed.
And then based on the response
we either adjust some of the
interface elements on screen or
if the player guessed right
then we say, hey, game's over
and we update our interface.
This method here, text field,
should change characters in
range replacement string.
All this really does is it makes
sure I can't enter more
digits in the text field then
are appropriate for this game.
So if I'm guessing a number
between 1 and 100, this will
stop me from entering more
than three digits.
Touches begin with event, this
really just makes sure I hide
the keyboard if I start
clicking on
other elements on screen.
And view did load sets up our
game model, sets our text
field delegate to self, so that
this text field should
change characters in range
method gets called.
So that's about all there
is to this application.
Feel free to try it out for
yourself for a little while.
Feel free to experiment.
Look at what it all does.
And when you're all done having
fun with this game,
which should take all of about
30 seconds, let's think about
how we would start adding some
game services to this
application.
And the very first thing
we'll want to do is
sign the user in.
And so we'll start tackling
that in the next lesson.